oh man
this might be the one time I'm
speechless
oh
thank you so much for this incredible
honor thank you for putting me in a
category
with these four extraordinary men
thank you Ben and Matt I still want to
see some ID
thank you Gus Van Zant for being so
subtle you're almost subliminal
I want to thank the cast and crew
especially the people of South Boston
you're a can of corn you're the best
and uh I want to thank Marcia for being
the woman who writes my soul on fire
every morning God bless you and most of
all I wanna
I wanna thank my father
up there the man who uh when I said I
wanted to be an actor he said wonderful
just have a backup profession like
welding
thank you God bless you
[Applause]